during the Christmas season many windows  in Germany shine with the light of  candle arches the tradition began with  coal miners in winter they would go  underground before sunrise and come back  up after sunset the candles represent  their yearning for light traditionally  the arches are made of wood they  originated in the Aerts Kabira mountains  they've made the town of Zion  world-famous every year thousands of  tourists come here from all over wooden  toys have been handcrafted here since  the 18th century  today most candle arches use electric  lights instead of candles in the depths  of winter they bring warmth and coziness  into people's living rooms  any other time it's impolite to look  through people's windows  but at this time of year the cattle  arches extend warm holiday greetings to  passers-by